back in buildings today the final grade
levels in the clark county school
district transition plan to
reopening campuses come back yeah but
the day
is not just about the academics we have
team coverage tonight
madison kimbrough is live with sports
and performing arts starting again but
first
kristen drummond has more on the issue
for some families getting their kids
back into the classroom kristin
well denise and brian students in grades
4 5
7 8 10 and 11 finally stepped back in
buildings
they joined their peers to start some
form of in-person instruction
at elementary schools they now allow
students back in the classroom
five days a week this is the most
popular option for families with
pre-kindergarten
to fifth grade students district data
shows more than 77
thousand came back today while roughly
60 thousand continued distance education
but
schools are receiving requests for
in-person learning
so much so some campuses created a wait
list for grade levels
a surprise for stephanie henry who found
out just a few days ago
she tells me her first grade son at
harris elementary school
is fourth on the list to get a slot
i didn't even know that our school has a
waiting list
every communication that i've seen so
far from the school
indicated that we didn't have some you
know
over pile of kids you know trying to go
back
all ccsd schools increased their
classroom capacity to
75 percent today going forward schools
must also follow health and safety
guidelines to reduce the spread of the
virus
which now includes three feet of social
distancing between students
instead of six feet now distance
education remains the most popular
choice for middle and high school
students right now
the district says more than 109 000 are
continuing with that option
compared to 36 000 in hybrid learning
split between cohort a
and b and while students are returning
to the classroom they will soon be able
to participate in sports and the
performing arts
madison kimbrough continues our coverage
from sierra vista high school where
the superintendent made the announcement
madison